um what's the one there vland Saga oh
right V Saga V Saga I almost I almost
didn't recognize it at first wait is
that anime yeah this was my anime of the
year I think uh jutu Ka obviously has
been a banger but I think overall this
year Vinland Saga gave me the most
complete package that just made me feel
do you know what surprises me about
vinin Saga season 2 I remember when it
started airing everyone was just like
everyone thought that people would get
put off by it because everyone was like
I sleep everyone everyone thought and me
included fans get put off anime fans
can't watch they're like oh my God it's
so slow and surprisingly I think I've
seen more even more posit well not
really surprisingly but I'm more
surprised that anime fans have patience
I can recognize Peak fiction when they
see it uh because this is a much slower
Arc it's much more character driven than
the previous one much less action and a
lot of people seem to enjoy it even more
uh yeah it was it was just amazing um
really excited to see where it goes
although I've read ahead a little bit um
and going to be very interesting to see
how they handle still Peak it's still
Peak yeah I'm going to be hopefully it
it gets a it continues to get a banger
adaptation yeah um and yeah I think it
was generally my anime of this year yeah
um I can't think of an anime that I F
found more compelling yeah that's about
it I mean it's the go yeah it is the Go
I mean I feel like this year for anime
was n necessarily a weak year at all we
just didn't get a lot of the strongest
anime we got this year were just very
much
sequels uh and continuations V was a
sequel continuation yeah exactly that's
a sequel continuation a lot of a lot of
anime there weren't as many strong new
Originals like new Originals or new IPS
coming up this year compared to last
year I thought um what's the one on the
bottom right I don't Rec that's that's a
YouTuber I got into it's called Bobby
broccoli oh yes I also good uh I saw the
video where he's talking about that guy
who invented a
new he's really like I thought that was
just fan art of
you kind of like you me I am my favorite
thing of this year no it's a YouTuber
called Bobby broley uh he's probably my
favorite YouTuber that I discovered this
year uh made some absolute bang of
videos I think every single video I get
super excited about even if I have no no
interest or don't care about it yeah his
presenting style is so unique uh and I
just find it really really his editing
is really good as well it's just amazing
content uh please go check him out it's
really good if you like documentary
style informational videos um with
fantastic storytelling um please check
it out it's so good so that's probably
my favorite YouTuber thatc this year
also shout out to Frederick for
releasing a [__] six hour Eve online
I still haven't finished that
one [__] years yeah that was want to
shout out is very recently summoning
salt released a a Mike Tyson's punch
video and halfway through the video he
talks about himself yeah because he I
remember he did a video about punch
records and it ended on him being the
record he's currently the record he's
really good at punch and everyone in the
comments is like so hype when you start
to Hype yourself up you go King well was
like when I watched that [__]
speedrun about the blue shell any% and
the guy making the video was the guy
who's the world record holder and I was
like oh he talking about himself from
the third person
that very So based um so yeah also what
else is based is [__] for you that
was probably my favorite I've listened
to a lot of music this year uh I did the
YouTube premium rewind or whatever the
[__] it was where I talk about yeah
where talk about all the music I I
listened to and I think this would have
been high but the problem is that tatua
isn't on any streaming platforms yeah
but I've definitely listened to him uh
more than I think anything else this
year uh just absolute Banger songs for
any occasion I think I commented on that
on your Twitter because you had
Thundercat on there I was
yeah was really good too I've listened
to mainly Funk uh like Funk with like uh
I don't know EDM I don't know what EDM
is I don't know [__] whatever
electronic F be and boobs be and and and
City pop which I got more into again
this year I've been trying to find this
record uh on vinyl for years and the
cheapest I've seen it go for is like
$300 I thought he was selling it as a
concert well go to the concert wait wait
wait wait well the original pressing
yeah they have the the Remake one yeah I
I I went to a bar I just happened to go
to a bar uh like 2 months ago and I
walked in and it was a wine bar where
the guy played records right and I [__]
you not the only two records he had like
he had he had a collection of records
and they were only de Punk and tats mash
and I was like there ain't no way there
ain't no way it's like your twin I was
like bro we're the same guy I was like
what the [__] he literally you like the
beeps and boobs too literally only had
death punk and tat Masa wow he didn't he
didn't even have that many albums but he
because they respect they have X but he
had all them on display and it was just
those and he was cycling between t ma
and D Punk and I was like B that's it
boss man's found the I found the best
part I found my local place do they
still make City poop uh no they make
City poop styled like tracks now now
that it's like kind of a trend in the
Indie scene but like you can't replicate
like the like ' 80s you could remake 80s
sound but I feel like the 8S is like
like pop music in general right like
with guys like the weekend who are like
bringing back the he samples c pop right
but it's not exactly the same it's not
the same thing I am very much down let's
sample more City Pop Let's get the vibe
let's do on because like when you get
when you get into City pop you're like
oh [__] yeah this this [__] slaps and
then you realize wait there's only a
limited supply of City poop out there
and then once you once you burn through
them all you're like oh [__] they're not
making
it where can I get my new fix man I
can't listen to the same 10 songs all
over again that's why I was so hyped
that tat was is still touring I was like
wait I got really sad when I started
looking up a lot of the artists that I
likeed for City pop and a lot of them
are dead yes and I was like well I guess
they're not performing something and I
was like I'd love to go and like
appreciate this music live unfortunately
so I I was really happy that at least
the goat Tatsu Masa kind of the father
of all of this is still touring cuz it's
like still so [__] you saw him live
and it's it's been great cuz one concert
I couldn't go to whenever I go to small
bars now in Japan especially like when
they like themed about music I'll be
like I like tat mas and every I swear to
God like this is like a nine out of 10
bar owners I go to they're like oh yeah
I've watched them live we just start
[__] like going off about how much we
love him yeah say saying you love yamas
tatero to like a bar man in Tokyo and is
the same level as like talking to anyone
in the anime industry and being like Oh
yeah berserk is my favorite yeah it
always go yeah it's like always great
I've I've been having a great and a lot
of time they'll just start playing it
for me and I'm like thanks man I
appreciate it uh so yeah I've I've you
know what a great album go check it out
if you haven't already fantastic album
and finally the deepest breath yeah my
favorite documentary this year SP about
podcast I wanted to watch this yeah I
think if you're going to watch any
documentary this year this is the one I
think the nature of documentary uh the
way that documentaries are filmed it's
so hard
to film a documentary about something
that's unfolding yeah because you don't
know where it's going how you know how
it's going to unfold um you know when
you're filming
right it is what just I don't know why
you saying this but reminded me of this
I just remind me of the the [__]
Boogie
29 the the Boogie documentary that came
out this
year also that was also a great
documentary that was also about that um
like this was
the the the the hardest part about do
documentary is if you do a documentary
about a story that's already finished
yeah you're going back you're asking
people hey what happened you get a
different perspective but it's so so so
rare to to get a documentary that is so
wellmade that is also filming everything
as it's unfolding because you just don't
know where the story is going to go and
and filming stuff is very expensive
having film Crews follow people around
is not cheap uh there there's only so
long you can do this for and so the
thing that's really amazing about this
and and soul crushing at the same time
is that all of this is unfolding is the
people are documenting it and following
it uh and and I won't say spoil much
about it but uh it is probably the most
like gut-wrenching and and heartbreaking
story uh a documentary I've watched in a
very long time and I really really
cannot stress enough I don't give a [__]
about diving uh but it is just a
fantastic very it's like an hour and a
half just watch it it's amazing you will
have a great time time um and I'm so
glad they didn't drag it out into like
nine episodes like Netflix loves doing
um I think a lot of documentaries can be
told in 2 hours just keep doing that not
every [__] court scene has to be
eight [__] episodes I don't need to
find out about everything just this is
the golden example of how to make an
amazing documentary with the added bonus
that it was being filmed as it was all
unraveling right which is so so rare um
really really good and the Boogie one
was also that was amazing too but uh but
my God special shout out to the Boogie
one but my [__] God what a [__]
sad piece of media um he's just a
terrible person I did not know why he
agreed to do it I don't know why I
agreed to do it cuz he needed money yeah
he's broke yeah that's true cuz he
needed more attention we're talking
about we talking about it now cuz
documentary yeah but like I watched him
on the financial there's a this guy does
a video it's called Financial audit and
he was on this and the guy was going
through his finances and it was just it
was like [__] bashing your head
against the wall he's like no I don't I
don't have that much he's like you spent
$900 this month on going out he's like
well I need to do that he's like why
he's like well because I can't feed my
family like I can't feed four people uh
unless I go to fast food for cheap and
he's like you can go to the grocery
store he's like well I like the taste
and it's like you are just you are
ruining your life and you have an excuse
for every single time you ruin your life